i wanted to do
this upgraded video of an older video
that i did
on a natural
antibiotic concoction now anything that
i say is not meant to replace your
medical care check with your doctor
before implementing what i'm about to
show you so i'm going to give you a
formula
of something you can make it's a
homemade
drink
that you'll take at the first sign of
sickness whether you get a tickle in
your throat or you feel run down or you
go through a stress event that's when
you're going to take this okay now a
couple things you need to know when you
take an antibiotic
realize that only kills bacteria it
doesn't kill viruses it doesn't kill
candida fungus things like that
what you're going to be taking
is you're going to be taking an
anti-microbial
remedy okay and we're going to borrow
these powerful
chemicals from plants now plants have
been developing these sophisticated
amazing chemicals that have all sorts of
properties for a long time before humans
and plants can't run away
so here they are stuck in the dirt and
so they are forced to develop all sorts
of defense mechanisms to help them
survive against a huge battle of not
just bacteria but funguses viruses pests
etc so what we're going to do is we're
going to tap into their chemicals use
them for our benefits so this is not
really an antibiotic it's an
antimicrobial so it's antibacterial
antivirus anti
parasite
and
there's going to be a lot less side
effects than an antibiotic which creates
antibiotic resistance
when you tap into the anti-microbial
effects from plants you don't get
the same resistance okay you don't get
the side effects you know when they talk
about herbal remedies there
they classify them as alternative
medicine but honestly pharmaceutical
companies get a lot of their ideas
from plants the first form of medicine
was from mother nature so from my
viewpoint
it appears that
modern medicine is really the
alternative to the original form of
medicine which came from plants mother
nature and natural remedies now just
realize too if you get a fever for
example you don't want to try to run out
and get some medication to try to
suppress the fever right off the bat
because a fever is part of your immune
system response and your immune system
is your greatest weapon against
infections a lot of people don't
talk about this they don't emphasize it
but your immune system is really what's
going to fight this thing off all we're
going to do is use natural compounds to
enhance our immune system defenses
so if you start taking things to
suppress a fever for example you may
find that the infection stays around a
lot longer okay so it's going to be
harder for you to resolve this situation
now the next thing is the most important
thing so if you checked out check back
in right now this is very very very
important
stress okay if you're going through
stress right now which you probably are
if you're sick because stress always is
the thing that triggers a lowered immune
system you must do whatever you can to
reduce this stress why because stress
activates cortisol
in the presence of high levels of
cortisol your immune system can not
function
it gets put on pause
and that means that pathogens can very
easily
invade your body so this whole thing
with cortisol and stress
must be resolved
also realize there's a natural form of
cortisol that you can also tap into and
that is vitamin d which is not really a
vitamin it's a hormone so the more you
can expose yourself to the sun or take
vitamin d the better the immune system
will work and you'll get the effects of
cortisol without all these side effects
because vitamin d does not paralyze the
immune system it modulates it it
controls the over reaction of an immune
system but helps improve the immune
system at the same time it increases
your immune system's ability to fight
back all right so we're going to be
using several things that we're going to
blend
in a 16 ounce mason jar and you're going
to keep this in the refrigerator
and it's going to actually get stronger
and more potent over time because it's
going to ferment so you're going to be
using garlic which has a certain
phytonutrient in fact it has like 33
additional
sulfur-based compounds that directly
help as an antimicrobial so garlic is
the most important thing you also use
ginger which is a very potent
antimicrobial you're going to be using
turmeric which is probably number two
after garlic in its antimicrobial
effects and as to curcumin in turmeric
that is going to help you and then we're
going to also use apple cider vinegar
okay now in the first video i did um i
recommended using two cups i found
that's that's pretty strong okay so
we're going to use a lot less but apple
cider vinegar is going to help acidify
your system to the point where your
phagocytes those little guys that help
clean up infection and help fight
microbes you can stimulate phagocytes
through
acidification
and then we're going to use a whole
lemon
with the peels the outside and
everything you're going to blend it
that's going to give your very potent
vitamin c
complex and about flavonoids to help the
immune system so you're not going to
just use lemon juice you're going to use
the whole lemon and then in this mixture
you're going to add
a very specific type of honey called
manuka honey now in the first video i
didn't recommend it in this video i'm
going to recommend it not a lot but just
some because of its very very powerful
antimicrobial effects so the benefits or
the pros of using this honey
far outweigh the cons as far as it
breaking your ketogenic
plant because this honey has a very
interesting chemical called mgo as well
as hydrogen peroxide that can really
speed things up for you so this is what
you're going to take 15 cloves of garlic
you're not going to have to put them
through a garlic press because you're
going to put them right into the blender
okay
so 15 garlic cloves take a whole lemon
an organic lemon stick that in the
blender now we're going to take one
tablespoon of turmeric powder then
you're going to create a fourth of a cup
of ginger so you're going to take some
ginger you're going to shred it on a
grater until you get about a fourth of a
cup you're going to put that in the
blender it's going to be very very spicy
now you're going to take a fourth of a
cup of this manuka honey
pour that into the blender you're going
to also add one ounce of extra virgin
olive oil why because this oil is going
to help you extract the fat soluble
plant-based compounds that are in these
plants now you could instead use coconut
oil if you want just use a heaping
teaspoon of that put it in the blender
because in order to extract fat soluble
compounds you need fat just like you put
oil on your salad because the
carotenoids plant-based chemicals in
your salad are fat soluble so they need
fat to be able to break them down okay
now we're going to add three ounces of
apple cider vinegar put that in the
blender and then add a cup of water now
you're going to blend this for about one
to two minutes and then you're going to
pour it into the 16 ounce mason jar okay
and then you're gonna finish it off with
some additional water until you're about
a half an inch from the top okay now
you're gonna seal the jar completely
tight and put it in the refrigerator now
you could start using this immediately
but just realize that the longer it's in
the fridge the better it's going to work
as far as the potency goes
and then at the first sign of a sickness
whether it's a tickle in the throat or
you're feeling run down you're tired
you're going to take a shot of this
drink okay
and then you can also take an additional
four shots spread out through the rest
of the day so there you have it a
natural antimicrobial
drink
now the next most important video for
you to watch
would be on the immune system okay so
check out that one right here
you